here's what would happen if you ate the  spiciest pepper in the world  as soon as you pop the pepper into your  mouth you'd begin to sweat this is the  first sign of your pain receptors being  activated it might not hit you right  away but you'll eventually start to feel  an intense burning sensation on your  tongue and then all around your mouth  as the pepper travels down your throat  more pain receptors will be activated  you'll continue to sweat and at this  point you might be crying  when the pepper reaches your stomach  it'll mix with your stomach acids and  your stomach will start to make more  acid than usual and more mucus to  protect itself from the capsaicin this  will make you nauseous  and then you'll be running to the  bathroom because when you digest spicy  food you absorb more water  finally you'll continue to sweat cry and  feel sick to your stomach for hours  until the pain eventually goes away so  don't eat it because